Hey guys, Pete here. This will be my
watchman episode 8 recap. The episode was
titled, "A God walks into Abar," all one
word, no space. It was written by Jeff
Jensen and Damon Lindelof and was
directed by Nicole Kassell. This video
will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened in HBO's Watchmen up
until this point so if you haven't
watched episode 8 yet go do that first
and then come back and watch this video.
The chicken or the egg.
the paradox. which came first the chicken
or the egg? the answer appears to be both.
at exactly the same time. if you knew how
a relationship was going to end, and if
it was gonna end tragically, would you
still go through with it? in this episode
we find out how Angela and Dr. Manhattan
got together how he ended up hiding as
the normal human being Cal in Tulsa, how
Adrian Veidt ended up on Europa, and what
the stakes are for the season, if not
series finale, next week. we also got a
sense of what it's like to be a god or
at least how this story's man who turned
into a god -
Dr. Manhattan experiences time.
technically speaking it's a pretty
amazing bit of storytelling in that we
get to experience the past present and
the future just as he does. this makes it
a memorable hour of television that even
though it frustrated me at times in the
sense that we knew how things were gonna
turn out, still managed to floor me in
the end. season one of watchmen turns out
to be a love story. one that ends
tragically and one that starts at
Eddy's bar in Saigon. what exactly did
we learn as we watch these two meet and
watch Dr. Manhattan try to convince her
to have dinner with him on the next
night? well we learned a bit about Jon
Osterman as a boy. we learned where Mr.
Phillips and Ms Crookshanks characters
came from and it turns out as a child
Jon Osterman and his father were fleeing
Germany during Hitler's rise to power. on
their journey out of Europe they are
helped along by a couple who live in the
English manor that John uses as a model
for his new world that he builds on
Europa later. after the events of the
squid attack and the end of the comic he
goes away to try to create life and we
find out how that all played out Dr.
Manhattan created his Adam and Eve
figures to be kinder and gentler beings
that were designed to care for others
instead of themselves. he made them not
in his image but in the image of the
couple that cared for him and his family
and helped them get out of Europe. as it
turns out this got boring for Dr.
Manhattan after a while. he says that all
his creations wanted to do is please him,
to adore him. their love was infinite which
is the very reason it's so unsatisfying
and why he had to leave his creations
behind and return to Earth.
during their conversation we also visit
Karnak which was Adrian Veidt's lair in
the Antarctic we see there how he
continued to create the periodic squid
falls to help maintain world peace and
we get a pretty good idea that Lady Trieu
has been keeping that up since he
travelled to Europa in 2009. when she
took over his companies they found out
he was missing when they traveled to
Karnak so she would have found all that
technology when they went there. in
Antarctica we find out where the device
came that Cal had inside of him that we
saw Angela pull out with the hammer in
the last episode we find out that the
ring was something that Adrian made 30
years ago it was plan "A" for amnesia it
was gonna make John forget who he was
but because of the way things played out
he had to go with Plan "B" which was
blowing him up which in the end didn't
work and yeah we all know how that
played out. so the ring fits into the
current timeline for John wanting to
have a normal life as a human being with
Angela.
in exchange Dr. Manhattan sends Veidt to
Europa so that he can experience the
Utopia that he was hoping to find after
he saved humanity. of course no one knows
that he did what he did except for a
handful of people,
so he's been kind of lost not knowing
what to do with himself. we see a pretty
interesting shot of him when we first
come in where he's pissed off because
they're making more bombs when he's
given them all these other options, you
know humanity is still continuing to
make bombs and we hear John say as
paradoxical as it sounds the bombs make
them feel safer. so we learn a lot and we
pretty much understand how we got to
where we're going. there's
more to learn about how things play out
in europa of course we get the end
credits scene here well we see that the
Phillipses and Crookshanks just want
Adrian Veidt to stay. they ask him if
he'll stay and he says no over and over
again as they smash tomatoes on his face.
in his dungeon the game warden brings in
a cake we noticed that there are seven
candles which means it's the seven-year
anniversary of his arrival on Europa. the
game warden explains that he was the
very first one, he is the Adam created by
Dr. Manhattan. after Adrian blows out the
candles he finds a horseshoe baked
inside the cake and he starts to dig
into the floor underneath his bed. back
in present time we watched things unfold
as we pick up right where we left off at
the end of the last episode we see Dr.
Manhattan wake up we see that the
Seventh Kavalry is outside they have a
tachyon cannon to transport him before
destroying him it also sets up its own
paradox as Jon's walking across the pool
which is probably important because he
tells her that she needs to see him do
that for later he sends the kids away to
be with Will Reeves at the dreamland
theater in Tulsa he explains that he's
expecting their arrival because he told
him about it back in 2009 in that
exchange Jon is still with Will Reeves
back in New York so Angela asks him how
did he know Crawford was a part of
Cyclops and how did he know that he had
that Klan robe in his closet of course
Will doesn't know because it's 10 years
ago so this sets up the idea who killed
Judd Crawford was it Angela or was it
Will? to dr. Manhattan it doesn't really
matter but to us as viewers we'd like to
find out I'm sure in the end they have
to face the Kavalry there's the
wonderful moment where Jon realizes
that he's in love with Angela the
question that she asked him before she's
getting ready to go out and fight and he
says I just told you you can't save me
and you're gonna try anyway it was
pretty badass they even gave this away
in the trailer and it still landed when
you see it in the actual episode outside
she does her best to fight them off
eventually Dr. Manhattan has to
intervene to save her life and just when
she thinks they won a Kavalry member
steps up to the cannon and transports
him away. so it is a really interesting
episode of television perhaps I'm a
softie but I really dig the way they
turned it into a love story it makes me
think about that famous quote about
puppets he says to Laurie at one point in
the comic we're all puppets Laurie I'm
just a puppet who can see the strings
and there is a kind of symmetry here
where in the comic he is a human that
turns into a god here he is a god who
turns back into human and for what
reason but love. so where does it leave
us for the final episode we did get
mention of a little elephant Adrian
Veidt says a little elephant told him
that Dr. Manhattan was on Europa that
would most likely be Lady Trieu and that
would likely tie her character into
saving Adrian from Europa it also makes
it more likely in my mind that Adrian is
the one she's referring to when she says
her father as far as we know
Dr. Manhattan is now in custody of the
Seventh Kavalry and Senator Keene they'll
be trying to move forward with their
plan to turn Keene into the new
Manhattan but we don't know what Will is
up to and we don't know what Lady Trieu is
up to except for that we know that she's
getting ready to make her millennium
clock go live so it should be a pretty
fantastic finale seeing how Angela tries
to rescue dr. Manhattan what happens
with Laurie Blake how Looking Glass will
figure in and I think most importantly
what Will Reeves has up his sleeve since
he has had quite a bit of time to think
about this and work with Lady Trieu he's
almost certainly on some kind of a plan
to fix the world just like Adrian Veidt
was trying to at the end of the comic so
let me know what you think in the
comments what do you think about this
episode what do you think about the big
reveals what did you think of
experiencing time like a god like dr.
Manhattan does do you think they pulled
it off did you find it frustrating that
you knew what was going to happen
a lot of cases and if that's the case do
you think that was the point it's pretty
interesting when you look at it through
that lens how will it affect the end of
the story
is what's about to happen to dr.
Manhattan another black spot or does he
know exactly how that's gonna play out
as soon as the episode ends I always go
to the Petey files to see what it can fill
in and this time it's more of a mystery
than anything else well it does at least
in my opinion confirm that he is lube
man that part seems to come out in his
writing about Fogdancer
the incident report the memo about
nothing ever ends is pretty confusing it
seems to be after whatever happens in
episode 9 but I don't think it really
gives us any answers as to how that's
gonna play out I'm gonna have to go back
and read it again and kind of pick it
apart and see if there's something more
that I'm missing but when I first looked
at it I was like wait a minute is this a
mistake that they put the wrong one up
and you have to look at it for yourself
but it's kind of interesting how they
had Petey look at the writing that he made
about Fogdancer when he was young and
how he interprets that now so it's
definitely interesting but not
necessarily filling in any answers as
far as I can tell overall I really
enjoyed this episode
I enjoyed the answer is the way they put
all the pieces together of the puzzle
that they laid out for us in the process
of writing this I'm just finding myself
liking it even more
it definitely tickles the part of me
that loved this story and the way that
it's built off of it and the big-picture
stuff that they're doing with Angela's
character it's all becoming more and
more exciting and rewarding from my
perspective the introduction of dr.
Manhattan certainly changes everything
especially after this episode where we
get that from his perspective but it
feels like they're pulling it off like
they're pulling off being able to give
us a story that hits home on a human
level even when it comes through that
perspective of someone who was human and
became a super-powered individual God
through the choices that he made as
mentioned I really want to see how this
all plays out as far as Lady Trieu's plans
how they line up with
Adrian's plans what he does when he
comes back what ends up happening with
Laurie and with Angela and how they're
gonna wrap this whole story up so please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe if you haven't already thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon